okay now that is a magic trick one book
two movies nicely done and as I continue
on my revisit of the Harry Potter films
we have arrived at Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 1 because yeah this
film kind of started a little bit of a
mini trend for a little while of book
adaptations being split into multiple
films as opposed to being adapted as
only one film it seems to finally be
done I think with the end of Hunger
Games I feel like that was kind of it
but yeah for a while there there was
this the last Twilight Hunger Games
which I mentioned The Hobbit oh my god
they managed to milk three out of that
one and it's not a trend I'm a fan of
that said I do actually kind of defend
it in this instance and I'll get to the
movie proper in a minute but I kind of
want to address the splitting first
since I am going to be reviewing each
film individually and if I don't talk
about it here where the heck else am I
gonna mention it so the reason I kind of
defend it in this particular instance is
that I personally am of the opinion that
there was the least you can get away
with cutting from Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows the book now you might
look at some of the earlier books just
as thick or thicker than that one and go
they trim stuff out of that what's so
special about this one well has to do
with the structure and the narrative and
what is actually taking up the time
because if you look at what was cut out
of all the other movies
it was subplots it was classroom scenes
it was
which it was stuff that this book
doesn't have for as long as it is
deathly hallows is actually pretty tight
as far as sticking to its plot it
doesn't diverge very much and pretty
much everything in there is relevant and
pretty important like they condensed
down some of the camping a little bit
but for the most part there isn't a lot
that you can just excise completely you
can't just remove entire characters or
entire scenes or entire subplots and
still have the story remain intact at
its heart the way that you could with
the other films and you one could make
the argument that given the size of the
franchise by franchise by this point and
this being the last one they could have
gotten away with basically pulling a
vengers endgame and making a three hour
plus movie and maybe they could have
pulled that off but you know that's not
what they opted for they made two
two-hour plus movies and again I'm not
gonna say that it would it would have
been just as good as a single film at
three three-and-a-half hours that might
have even been better I'm not gonna say
it wouldn't be but I don't begrudge the
decision to split in this case just cuz
I don't think they have the room to cut
as much with this story I just don't
think they did uh now that said I do
understand also there was a a returns
box-office motivation to do it so while
I just defended it from an artistic and
adaptation standpoint I do understand
that was not the only reason they
decided to do that probably wasn't even
the primary reason I'm just saying that
because of that I'm more okay with it
than some other folks I have seen okay
okay so let's talk about the thing
itself this is obviously a pretty big
divergence from the other films just as
the book was a pretty big divergence
from the other books we are not at the
anymore we are completely broken free of
the structure of the school year which
is how every other book and film has
been built a little bit more so the
books because again because of all the
subplots and classroom time that had to
be trimmed to in order for the movies to
be a reasonable runtime there the films
weren't quite as rigidly structured
around the school year as the books were
but they still were all set at Hogwarts
and all worked within that same
framework
this is untethered this is doing its own
thing pretty much from the get-go and
some things I think even doing a little
bit better so for instance well let's
start talking about character's death
because the thing opens with with more
than a few of those so like spoilers
like I shouldn't have to say that not
for a revisit review anyways so like
Hedwig I think her death hit me a lot
harder in this than it did in the book
in the book
Hedwig dying was not dissimilar to
Sirius Black dying it just kind of
happened and I wasn't even like I was
sad but I was like that was so quick I
didn't even know what to make of it
and there's also mad-eye moody dying
which we don't actually see happen and
we don't see happen in the book either I
don't Hank it's been long time since
I've read the books like give me a
slight break on that but there's always
been a problem for me on that and
actually it's been a problem I should
have mentioned this in prison in sorry
not Prisoner of Azkaban
in order the Phoenix because it actually
came up there for me as well which is a
time mad-eye moody has reappeared post
Goblet of Fire I don't know what to make
of him and more specifically in regards
to the fact that he dies in this story
I'm not impacted by that the way I'm
pretty sure Rowling and the filmmakers
want me to be for one very simple reason
I don't know
my movie and the thing is the films and
also the books can trick you into
thinking you know mad-eye moody but you
need to remember the character we spent
all this time with in Goblet of Fire
that wasn't him that was someone
pretending to be him and even if we make
the leap that it was a 100% accurate
depiction and faking of mad-eye moody ie
aside from the setting up the stuff for
Voldemort literally everything that
Barty Crouch jr. pretending to be a mad
I moody did was exactly what mad-eye
moody himself would do which honestly
that's a big leap
but even if we make that leap he still
never really built a relationship with
Harry not himself a fake version of him
did he himself didn't have that time he
himself was never Harry's teacher and
I'm not saying that means you can't
bring the character bag it just means
that I've never forgotten the fact that
I don't actually know him the fellows
trying to trick you into thinking you do
but you don't not really and I've always
been acutely aware of that so his death
and that both in the book and in the
film just never hit me the way that it
was supposed to also this this story I
remember watching it because I watched
it I was gonna say I watched it with Liz
I was I watch it with Liz in the room
she was working on on work stuff and and
she asked me to put on something that
she could basically semi ignore um and I
opted for this because I had to watch it
anyways and of course she'd seen it
before
so we noted like the the marriage of
Bill and Fleur Delacour
that is if anyone else feel like that's
really weird like really weird
because when did they ever meet because
bill was done with Hogwarts I mean Hank
before the book series even started
saying nothing of Goblet of Fire when
did they meet what monstrous coincidence
that this character who we knew from one
time before just so happened at some
point somewhere in her life to meet and
fall in love with this person who at
least in the films we actually haven't
seen before this either but whether
these connections all these people we
already know just so she can show up
back into the story it's really weird
it's really contrived you know else is
really contrived Thomson Lupin know at
this point like I I know some people say
it to be cheeky but like honestly I buy
it a lot better than i buy the romance
they just the idea that they are each
other's beard and if you don't know that
terminology given that both characters
are actually to varying degrees kind of
queer coded within the lgbtq+ community
a beard is what you call the fake
straight relationship a queer person has
to cover the fact that they are queer
and like I buy that a lot more than I
buy their relationship aside from the
fact like the age gap is a little creepy
like that
it also talks I didn't mention this in
order of the Phoenix tux kinda gets the
short shrift throughout this film series
which is a shame because I really liked
her in the books it's it's a little
irritating that's that's a little weird
and annoying but having said all that
the performances are still really really
good across the board they remain so
especially between the core three of Ron
Hermione and Harry and I know some
people especially people who really have
a strong preference for book Ron over
movie Ron have some real issues with
some of the stuff they
with him at this point I've come to
embrace movie Ron as being a slightly
different entity and I think Rupert
Grint delivers on the performance for
the version of Ron that he has been
portraying up to this point if that
still doesn't work for you cool I'm not
saying you have to swallow it I'm just
saying it works for me
there's a great deal of tension in the
entire film it's it's a really it does a
really good job of making the danger
feel ever-present
at every turn no matter what they're
doing no matter if there are in the
woods infiltrating the Ministry of Magic
in Godric's Hollow no matter where they
are no matter what they're doing it
feels dangerous at all times which it
should the other thing that I wanted to
mention though visually and also audio
wise I put this out in a tweet in case I
forgot to mention it the volume
discrepancy on this thing between the
action scenes and the dialogue scenes
man that was irritating I don't know if
it's like that because like it's
optimized for surround sound which I
don't have and that's what's throwing it
off I don't know but I I had to have my
remote control right next to me because
I had to turn the volume down every
single time an action scene started
because it just was so loud and then as
soon as it ended I had to turn the
volume back up again because the
dialogue scenes are so much quieter that
disparity really irritating and then
visually I feel like the previous film I
feel like a half-blood Prince did a
pretty good job of having a sense of
darkness while still being more or less
visually coherent this one especially in
some of the outdoor scenes in some of
the some of the stuff in the woods and
at night and darker scenes and whatnot
they what I think that we're trying to
go for a natural lighting thing the
thing is natural lighting at night you
can't see and guess what there are swath
of this film you can't see
what is going on it's really frustrating
especially because again at least to me
the previous film did a really good
balance from the visual standpoint yet
this one is so drenched in black hey
again I know you're trying to go for
like the the dark visuals because it's a
darker story but like this is too much
the as a film taking completely unto
itself even though I did kind of defend
the decision to split the stories and I
do think the point at which they decide
to put the split was the place where it
makes sense to put it I think Bobby's
death and Voldemort getting the wand is
a place that makes a lot of sense you
get a cliffhanger into it and you have a
and you have a ending and a loss that
will invigorate the heroes and going
into the next film so it was well chosen
as far as that goes but because that is
not meant to be the end of this story it
as originally written it does have a
weird sort of flow and structure it
doesn't have a standard three-act
structure which does not necessarily dam
a film not everything has to have a 3x
scripts
3x structure but given that the previous
films had had fairly rigid structure in
terms of how they progress in the pace
at which they did it to have a film
later in that same series mess with and
break and reshuffle that structure so
much I which again it had to since it's
not actually telling a complete story in
one go it does make it feel a little bit
odd because even by the metric of its
own series it feels weird the flow is
strange I'm not necessarily sure there
was a way around that if you accept the
decision to split this into two halves
but I feel like I would have been remiss
to not mention it I don't really have a
ton to say apart from just praising the
acting and especially the trio I mean
all the other actors are good as well no
one else
it's a highlight to the same degree oh I
really liked the animated segment
describing the deathly hallows and their
origin I really like the visual styling
the sort of puppetry sort of looking
marionette almost looking aspect to it I
quite enjoyed that I really liked that
visual presentation of it and yeah I
think it's a solid build-up to the to
the next one although I suspect when I
rank these at the end of this exercise
this is going to be more towards the
bottom because while it serves the
purpose it needs to which is to set us
up for a big blowout finish with the
with the eighth film actually taken as a
thing unto itself that there there's a
lot of stumbling points in it I still
enjoy it but yeah it's a bit of an
awkward beast this one Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows Part 1 you've seen
it what do you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something on the
comments let's talk about it there's a
bunch of stuff to do down there as well
you can like and subscribe that helps me
out quite a bit there's a patreon down
there if you want to help me keep this
thing going that helps me out even more
there's links other stuff besides click
on things they'll take your places
or don't you don't have to because at
the end of the day your council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]